複写リクしためっちゃを怒ってるのがなあそうですよねあれかと思って暗くなった
何マジでっ
楽しんだけど結合は強さのあるな
me
ばなんかあ
いっぱいある意味でいいんだっ
[音楽]
4日ノーツの-ですというで今日なんですけども
を性に惹かれたが静岡についているということで歳ちょっと一市長に静岡呼び出されて
どうしても静岡のこの場所で待っておいてほしいことがある
なんかよくわかんないんですとりあえず待ってますやばすぎるでしょ
この唐突に静岡校きてこういう風になってくるとなんでが戻っキーナン
からって言うからやっぱする肇社長が技はが俺を民放にちょっと早速前回の動画で私が
あれ実は初10万円かかってるんですよ私の車 atc e 86をですね大改造して
惹かれさんのカラーにしてしまいました
ちょっとかっこいい感じでちょっといたねどうぞ
[音楽]
持ってい
5分
me
で何時コネットだから調べたんですけども金と黒のセンターワーって半分になっている
まあ多分世界で今伴いやすいんですよこれトイロおそらく史上初の光るカラーのくる
ようになっておりますそれで今日のだがは光るカラーの車でひかれさん迎えに行ってみ
たらどういう反応するのかということでお台場ピュア
やまったから何かあるんですけど最近無事故無違反5年間続いてゴールド免許になり
ましたはじめ社長です運転日だそうに見えるんですけど
ディベートちゃんどうしておりますそういうわけでも東静岡駅に一人様ってレっぽいん
でちょっと寒いでの待たせて申し訳ないんですけども
早速向かいに行ってみようかなと思いますさあそんな話そうスペル方もすでに到着する
前婦さんの声を聞いてみましょう枚さーん
んでこうふっ納骨かっこいいっってかっこいいですよねー
あああれはいはどれでちょっとは聞かれた迎えみてください
二安いよかっこいいですよね creema ガンガン迎えに行ってみましょう
これ惹かれさんの色にしたいのと聞かれたにこれミスティック発注負けてますからそれ
なりのプレッシャーヌー
ねそうみんなガン見するよね横から見ると誰も見向きもしないんですけども照明から
この車見るとめっちゃ南いるんですよ
空から来ると渡すジャーナルしかしてそれを言うことですねんかマジ
なあこの特典を退けはもう惹かれさん目の前で私どういう反応を見せてくれるの
でしょうか
なんで俺らんだったっていうのは主義もんだこれはちっまあだったところで俺を a
んじゃないじゃないかなとでは品としてきた俺もなんかマジ超低空以降の理由は彼ら
よりも持ってくる
俺はロレああ
クシャリっ子しためっちゃを怒ってるかな
なあそうですよねあれかと思ってたら
何マジ
うーんまあ信者けどお芝居強さのあるだ
僕らじゃん
ポッ
お待たせしましたーー
1回埋めていいですかうん
4日
wh
ni
ああああああ
ノーズがいけるだろはっはー
合浦区でこのためにこれはザックにかけません
えっ
4日
tan
でプロ初場所は車古木ます aa 1月からさん
僕は光さんのために聞かる感じました
はっはっはっならないで方ですとなんでこれはたの俺じゃないだにはじめ所は作った
プロがすぐ絶妙にだそれ
[音楽]
ブービー著
は想像以上に悪くないやそうなんですよ2とした
ありやちょっと悪ふざけで作ってみたっていうのはめっちゃかっこいいってかっこえ
えっはそうなんよ欲しいのかよ
けど
いやーすごい
ni
ています
いやーこれはそれじゃ目立つな俺をしたかったんですよもうこんな俺が4月企画やっ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
car
あっはぁ